questions to wrap this up one obviously
you've got a position on Bitcoin I
actually think it's a pretty valid
concern like you're gonna take the other
side or the bearer side the argument you
make I think is that the perfect
argument what would have to happen for
you to change your mind
it'd have to be so easy to use it's a
no-brainer
it has to be completely friction free
and understandable by everybody first
and then then and then you can say it's
an alternative to gold as a store of
value but in terms of being a way to UM
transact you know whether it's just
transfers of funds or whatever you've
got to be able to spend it you know cuz
right now you still have to convert it
for anything that you want and as long
as you have to convert it you're still
dependent on fiha no matter what you say
right and I can trade bananas easier as
a commodity that I could trade Bitcoin
right and I can still eat that banana
before it goes bad and get all my
potassium for my workout you know I
can't I you know I can't even you know
with gold at least a gold coin right or
I can point I can use your gold bar as
furniture you know but with Bitcoin it's
virtual and you know that's the beauty
and that's its problem and so one you're
gonna have to make it friction free so
grandma can do it because now the fact
that we're arguing so much about it and
you have so many stands about Bitcoin or
you know for Bitcoin that just proves
the point you know that it's difficult
and to you can't spend it on anything
you know I think we've spent we put it
up for the Mavs we did it originally
four years ago and no one bought
anything now we're taking Bitcoin to
please go buy everything a Bitcoin I'm
fine with that right and I think we
brought in $130 and that's all the
Bitcoin that I own right now yeah yeah I
think part of it too is a user
experience nothing has to improve the
big question is is this email you know
25 years ago and it does improve or does
it that's opportunity and risk that
people take right yeah plus you know
there's so many um peculiarities to
Bitcoin right the having right you know
the mining in that you know the fact
that blockchain is a great opportunity
but in reality we haven't seen
blockchain applications really take off
you know and there's uncertainty with
all the different types of Kryptos you
know and the arguments between all the
types of Kryptos you know these are
things that just you know create more
and more confusion and diminish the
confidence and so yeah I get all the
arguments I've seen all the charts right
I understand that you know the profit
potential problems let's be out but you
know two bitcoins potential benefit if
everything goes into the [ __ ] because
we're pretty so much money and there's
global implications Bitcoin has got
something to deal with and something to
say and if we don't Bitcoin get nothing
I actually appreciate your detract mints
because they're usually pretty rational
right so I tend to agree and I think
it's the right position to take on the
other side